in the education sector in the dean's
army joins us in the studio minister
good to see you and of course
congratulations on the new job but but
let's dwell on on what we heard and he
did what we didn't hear from the prime
minister yesterday was it a mistake for
boris johnson not to mention in his
speech three of the big live issues for
the country at the moment supply
shortages petrol cues and the biggest
overnight cutting benefits that we have
ever seen
well i think what he did talk about is
skill skill skills which is very much
my department department of education he
spoke about the leveling up of
opportunity we've announced
a 3 000 pound
effectively bonus to
early teaching um candidates who we can
retain um in years one to five and
hopefully in those areas of the country
that the children need the most
um we
announce half a billion pounds to help
those who will find it most difficult
with their fuel bills
with the utility bills because of the
gas price increase that's obviously
global because the global economy is
rebounding
that was all during party conference or
the beginning of party conference sure
sure but but these are these are issues
that have been on the front page of
every newspaper for for weeks now and
the prime minister pointedly didn't
mention the day after a prime minister's
speech to party conference we generally
have page after page of analysis in the
newspapers of the policy announcements
that are made instead we have page after
page of the jokes that he made
it's worth remembering
that literally
a few weeks before party conference
he announced probably the biggest and
most important
uh policy that successive governments
including conservative governments i
have to say were unable to deal with or
deliver which is adult social care 36
billion pounds
going into fiction
and that was a massive announcement i'm
sorry i'm sorry minister but we're
talking about the speech yesterday i
hear you but i'm just i'm just saying
put it in perspective right only only
literally few weeks before party
conference
we announced what is i think an
extraordinary achievement by a prime
minister
ever since i joined the conservative
party successive governments labor and
conservatives
and they're never dealt with i
understand this but there is more than a
degree of frustration particularly
amongst people who are working looking
for work but on universal credit that he
didn't mention it it was as i mentioned
the single biggest cut to welfare that
we have seen in this country and he
couldn't be bothered to mention it as we
enter into colder winter with fuel
prices rising with food prices rising
you know and with well with jobs let's
just say for some people at a premium
and it's really important to remember
that
as we
arrived in manchester we announced half
a billion pounds
for winter for those families that will
find it most difficult on their fuel
bills on their
utility bills
according to the gather institute 840
000 people including almost 300 000
children are going to be pushed into
poverty as a result of the universal
credit uplift ending and he didn't
mention it i'm asking the question again
that i started with why didn't he why
did he choose to skirt the biggest
political issues of the day i'd i will
this is why i would respectfully
disagree because one we announced
literally as we were arriving in
manchester half a billion pounds for
those families for this winter on by the
way on top of the uh winter fuel
allowance the warm homes got all the
things for the most vulnerable families
to be able to help them over winter
months the
20 pounds uplift was always temporary
now
it was an important part of the 400
billion it was about 9 billion of the
400 billion that rishi sunak wrapped his
arms around the people who are most
vulnerable on the lowest pay many of
them on universal credit through the
pandemic but as we come out the other
end where we're seeing
jobs
market being incredibly dynamic there's
two million fewer
people out of work today than forecasts
through the probably four million
households with 3.3 million children
seeing their incomes drop by more than a
thousand pounds and the prime minister
can't be bothered to mention it the
reason i keep pushing on this point the
reason i keep pushing on this point is
it has felt at points during this party
conference that the conservatives have
been you know somewhat out of touch i
mean you had uh terese coffey you know
singing along you know on the at the
point at which the universal credit
uplift was removed singing along at a
karaoke event you've got another
colleague peter bottomley talking about
the grim struggle of living on an mp's
82 000 pounds a year salary i mean where
is the connection to people who are
struggling at the moment where is the we
had plenty of jokes from the prime
minister yesterday but where was he when
when some people wanted him to reach out
to the poorest
and some of the hardest working people
in this country and reassure them that
everything is going to be okay and he
glossed over it well
so where i'm
slightly hoping that as well as quoting
things like the 20 pound uplift you
would also quote the national living
wage has delivered four thousand pounds
more into people's uh pay packets uh
because of what boris johnson could have
made an announcement on raising minimum
wage yesterday
but that's done in you know there's a
there's a process to that indeed but you
didn't mention the half a billion which
we announced as we arrived in manchester
for those same vulnerable families that
will be delivered by their local
councils because they're the ones who
know them best for their for their fuel
bills for their utility bills and for
their food needs that's the same people
who may fall through the
safety net now
lots of other people
my job is to skill them up skill we've
got a lifetime skills guarantee that
when i was
the the apprentice of tsar in the
coalition government
if you told me there'll be a prime
minister who will offer people at any
age the ability to pull off modules to
reskill and upskill and we would back
them out of a bit in your arm off this
prime minister delivered that but with
that czar's hat on look at the papers
this morning and look at the reaction
from the business community who to a
greater or lesser extent feel that the
conservatives are not the party of
business anymore i mean the boss of
iceland himself a committed brexiteer
says he's been warning for labor about
labour shortages for months with
absolutely no response from the
government you know the adam smith
institute described the rhetoric from
the prime minister yesterday as
economically illiterate we heard from
the conservative think tank bright blue
the public will soon tire of boris's
banter if the government does not get a
grip of mounting crises the polling that
we have done shows that his speech
outside the conference hall was less
well received than that of kier stammer
why is this party a party that has long
held its business credentials up as a
reason to vote for it on a war path with
business at the moment well i don't
agree with you first thing i would say
is we are the party i haven't made these
i want something no i don't let me just
give you
my side of this i met with the cbi tony
danker and karen balamori
and we all agree
that actually
look at what we've done on um seasonal
workers increased the number by five
thousand eight gb drivers increase the
visa numbers by five thousand but
that
visa bit is not the answer the long-term
answer the long-term answer is you work
with business
let me try and bring it to life for you
in the food industry i went to wilmore
which is in my constituents one of the
biggest suppliers of fresh food and veg
to the supermarkets i said how are you
doing they said we're doing well yes
there are pressures because of all the
issues that you've just described but
because of rishi sunax
tax break for us to invest in equipment
we can get 25 of that back we're
investing in equipment and and hold on
and upskilling and
reskinning and increasing the wages of
our people because they're going to have
to work with automation and by way of
contrast the federation of small
businesses says it's equally remarkable
to hear the benefits of a low tax
economy wanted when the government has
just signed off a hike in national
insurance contributions which we
estimate will cost at least 50 000 jobs
so what i would say to everybody is look
let's work together we
we've seen retailers who've invested in
technology and have done really well
others like topshop and topman didn't
make that investment and haven't done so
well we've seen smes take advantage 100
billion pounds of grants and loans to
support smes that is what this
government is doing to help business
let's do this together let's produce
that high-wage high school economy
because it is doable let's talk then on
on your briefing there was a policy
exchange event that you spoke at on on
sunday in the fringe of the conference
you were asked whether or not you
planned to get school children to wear
masks you said we have got contingency
plans in the department if we see
further disruption do those contingency
plans include a return to children
wearing masks
perhaps even a return to bubbles
so the good news is that and thanks to
the brilliant teachers and support staff
and parents and and children 99 of
schools are open attendance has gone up
the last set of figures i looked at was
about 90 percent um that obviously will
will will fluctuate depending on
infection rates yeah but the the
my priority
is to protect education keep those
schools open rachel de souza the
children's commissioner had a 500 000
survey of of children
at school 200 2 and a half thousand
children of gypsy and roma families yeah
sixteen thousand of sendy they all said
they want to be back at school this is
the they value that interaction with
them come on tell me so we have the
bubbles right so we've got a contingency
plan
as you would expect me to do as
especially of the vaccines minister does
it contain it it contains lots of lots
of consistency including masks yeah
absolutely but at the moment at the
moment i don't want to return to bubbles
because actually you saw the fall-off in
attendance which really does harm mental
well-being mental health for children
you saw in in richard susan's survey and
i don't want to return to that and my
priorities to protect education and keep
schools open and children at school
we're all very fond of recycling these
days no more so than yourself with this
three thousand pounds up list for
teachers this was a policy that was
binned a couple of years ago
it's a policy that worked this is
different and better because the
teachers have been eligible for five
years um to be able to to take advantage
of that up to 3 000 pounds
if they stay in the profession in maths
in chemistry in computing in physics in
the schools that most need them sure
just on ventilation though where are we
in terms of the pilot programs they're
getting the co2 monitors into schools
and possibly we're getting to a stage
where schools can't simply have the
windows open anymore so what are we
doing about that so we're getting 300
000 co2 monitors into schools the last
time your predecessor spoke there he
talked to me about that yeah have we not
made any progress no we have we have
absolutely they they're going out by
the end of this month we would have
the the real uplift in those uh numbers
into schools really important we're also
looking at ventilation and how we
make sure that schools have access to uh
ventilation how do they do that how many
sheets are lots of there's lots of
technology no but how might you
ease their access to that technology
we're talking about kind of the central
government buying it are we talking
about grants being given to schools so
i'm looking to buy a quantity and then
also create a market
that schools can access if they need
them excellent very very briefly on your
old brief
the vaccines minister story that
appeared yesterday did france really
steal five thousand doses of the visa
vaccine from us i can't possibly comment
yes you can
look
we you know
we we had a challenging
situation with the eu commission uh we
always took the view that um we don't
block any exports of any vaccines from
the uk the way we got our vaccines
through
having good contracts and kate bingham
to do brilliant jobs as did the vaccines
task force as a whole uh uh in
delivering those contracts and you know
the eu commission worked with us on
making sure our supplies from uh belgium
fires and elsewhere worked well and of
course we did everything we can to help
france and other countries as well uh
website minister good to see you this
morning thanks being with us